[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Freitag die vom Sport hat Norbert
Lehmann
und das sind die Themen von heute
massive russische Angriffe auf die
Energieversorgung noch mehr Ukraine
leiden nach Stromausfällen unter Kälte
und Dunkelheit
weniger Risiko für Whistleblower wer
Rechtsverstöße im Beruf meldet wird
künftig besser geschützt beschließt der
Bundestag
und riesen Aquarium in Berliner Hotel
geplatzt Wassermassen verletzen zwei
Menschen und beschädigen Gebäude
[Musik]
der internationale Karlspreis eine der
bedeutendsten europäischen Ehrungen geht
im kommenden Jahr an das ukrainische
Volk und an Präsident silensky weil sie
nicht nur ihr Land verteidigen sondern
auch Europa und die europäischen Werte
so die Begründung dafür zahlen sie einen
hohen Preis gerade erlebt die Ukraine
eine der schlimmsten Angriffswellen seit
Kriegsbeginn schwere Treffer und
Stromausfälle melden die Millionenstadt
Harke und die Region und nie pro in der
Stadt kriviri schlugen Geschosse in
einem Wohnblock ein und töteten zwei
Menschen und allein die Hauptstadt Kiew
wurde laut ukrainischer Luftabwehr mit
dutzenden Raketen angegriffen eine Brühl
die meisten Wohnungen bleiben dunkel
heute Abend in Kiew 40 russische Raketen
waren am Morgen Richtung Hauptstadt
geflogen 37 wurden abgeschossen sagen
die Ukraine
die Menschen suchen Schutz in der U-Bahn
fast schon trauriger Alltag
das ganze Land wird angegriffen
getroffen werden Wohnhäuser wie in
Krefeld der Heimatstadt von Präsident
silenski Hauptziel aber ist wieder die
Infrastruktur in vielen ukrainischen
Städten
es ist schwer angsteinflößend aber was
kann man machen man muss abwarten bis
alles repariert wird und bis der Sieg
kommt
[Musik]
es gibt keinen Strom in ganz Rake Wasser
ist da Strom und Heizung nicht
1,2 Millionen Menschen sind allein in
Harke vom Osten des Landes betroffen es
ist kalt - gerade die Wohnungen können
schnell aus viele Geschäfte haben heute
erst gar nicht geöffnet wer kann bleibt
zu Hause
vier Stunden 20 Minuten Luftalarm in der
gesamten Ukraine das war heute die 9
russische Angriffswelle seit Anfang
Oktober und sie hat offenbar vor allen
Dingen ein Ziel die Zivilbevölkerung zu
zermürben
Anlagen für die Wasser- und
Wärmeversorgung sollen in harkef als
erstes repariert werden erst dann kommen
die Wohnhäuser an die Reihe es wird wohl
eine kalte Nacht in Harke
zum Alltag in der Ukraine gehören
mittlerweile auch die vielen
Beerdigungen der Opfer von Zivilisten
wie von Soldaten auch davon berichtet
eine Brühl
[Musik]
wenn auf dem Unabhängigkeitsplatz in
dugno die Nationalhymne ertöntester
Anlass meistens traurig
[Musik]
Juri hussak war 29 als er starb als
Soldat im Kampf um bachmut Ehre sei Gott
Ehre der Ukraine betet der Priester bis
zu 13.000 ukrainische Soldaten sind seit
Kriegsbeginn gefallen das sind die
neuesten Zahlen aus dem Präsidentenbüro
in dugno erinnern Plakate an die Toten
Mitbürger
wir müssen uns jeden Tag an die
gefallenen Soldaten erinnern uns daran
erinnern welches Opfer sie bringen und
dann das tun was uns selbst möglich ist
Duplo verneigt sich an diesem Tag vor
Juri der sein Leben gelassen hat im
Kampf für sein Land
vor der Kirche treffen wir Soldaten
seiner Einheit
ist das nicht ein sehr großes Opfer dass
die Ukraine bringt wollen wir wissen ja
sehr die Besten sterben
mehr als drei Stunden dauern die
Trauerfeierlichkeiten für Juri hussak
fünf Kilometer weit wird sein Sarg durch
die Stadt zum Friedhof geleitet in
völliger Stille
es ist ein langer Abschied am Ende eines
kurzen Lebens
Einigkeit in fast allen Punkten so
endete der letzte EU-Gipfel dieses
Jahres neue Sanktionen gegen Russland
wurden beschlossen genauso wie weitere
Hilfen für die Ukraine und Ungarn muss
wegen schlechter Korruptionsbekämpfung
vorerst auf Milliardenzahlungen
verzichten zudem gab es eine
grundsätzliche Einigung den
Einkaufspreis für Gas zu deckeln die
Grenze liegt allerdings so hoch das
Bundeskanzler Scholz hofft dass der
Deckel nie zur Anwendung kommen wird
die Gas- und Energieversorgung über den
Winter das war auch Thema beim aktuellen
ZDF Politbarometer guten Abend Matthias
da sind die Befragten aber eher
optimistisch ja so ist es das ist in
diesem Winter zu ernsthaften Problemen
bei der Versorgung mit Erdgas kommt
glauben nur 29% der Befragten gut zwei
Drittel rechnen da nicht mit Problemen
größere Stromausfälle erwarten 24
Prozent
73% sehen keinen Blackout kommen
anderes aktuelles Thema die
maskenpflicht im öffentlichen Nahverkehr
da gibt es zumindest in einem Punkt eine
große Mehrheit dazu kommen wir gleich
immer weniger Menschen fürchten wegen
Corona um ihre Gesundheit aber es sind
ja noch viele andere Viren unterwegs der
Krankenstand ist hoch wohl auch deshalb
ist eine knappe Mehrheit von 52 Prozent
für die maskenpflicht im öffentlichen
Nahverkehr und eine sehr klare Mehrheit
von 85% will dabei keine Alleingänge der
Länder sondern einheitliche Regeln für
ganz Deutschland dieses Jahr 2022 ist
außergewöhnlich Krieg in Europa hohe
Inflation wie erleben dass die Menschen
wie blicken sie in die Zukunft ja trotz
all dieser Krisen sind die Deutschen
verhalten optimistisch das Jahr 2022 war
für mich eher gut das Sagen 64 Prozent
ein Drittel findet es war schlecht das
nächste Jahr wird besser für mich
erwarten 25 Prozent 58 Prozent gehen
davon aus dass
24 in etwa gleich wird und nur 15%
glauben das neue Jahr wird schlechter
für sie ein bisschen Zuversicht also zum
Jahresende können wir alle brauchen
vielen Dank Matthias das komplette
Politbarometer gibt es heute Abend im
heute-journal um 10 oder jederzeit
online unter zdf.de
wer auf Missstände wie Korruption oder
Betrug am Arbeitsplatz oder in seinem
Umfeld hinweist soll künftig besser vor
beruflichen Strafaktionen geschützt sein
das hat der Bundestag heute beschlossen
Deutschland setzt damit verspätet eine
EU-Richtlinie um künftig müssen
Unternehmen auf Hinweise reagieren auch
wenn Sie anonym sind Frank Buchwald hat
Details
der Skandal erschütterte ganz
Deutschland ein Apotheker in Bottrop
fälschte Krebsmedikamente die Sache kam
ans Licht weil Mitarbeiter ihren Chef
angezeigt hatten bisher konnte das
arbeitsrechtliche Folgen haben ein neues
Gesetz soll Whistleblower nun jedoch
absichern auf der einen Seite schützen
wir hinweisgebende Personen vor
Repressalien und auf der anderen Seite
verpflichten wir Organisationen dazu
entsprechende Stellen einzurichten die
professionell mit diesen Hinweisen
umgehen können nach dem neuen Gesetz
können Whistleblower über Meldestellen
in und außerhalb von Unternehmen
vertraulich notfalls auch anonym auf
strafbare Handlungen Hinweisen dazu
zählen auch Steuerdelikte beamte können
verfassungswidriges Verhalten von
Kollegen oder Vorgesetzten melden etwa
extremistische Aussagen bürokratisch sei
das und teuer kritisiert die Opposition
90.000 Unternehmen in unserem Land
belasten sie durch dieses Gesetz mit
zusätzlichen Kosten und neuer Bürokratie
die kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen in ihren Wahlkreisen werden
sich sicher über dieses
Weihnachtsgeschenk in ihrem auch
Hausaufgabenheft freuen weiterer
Kritikpunkt das Gesetz greife nicht
sobald Vorgänge in Behörden als
vertraulich eingestuft sein das ist zum
Beispiel der Bereich der nationalen
Sicherheit auch Verschluss Sachen fallen
nicht unter diesen Schutzschirm und das
ist ganz kritisch aus unserer Sicht weil
das ist ein ganz intransparenter Bereich
an die Öffentlichkeit dürften
Whistleblower sich erst dann wenden wenn
interne Meldungen ohne Erfolg bleiben
und wenn es dann rein zufällig in die
Medien kommt weil es nicht abgestellt
worden ist ja wen wird man wohl als
erstes Verdächtigen das ist genau die
Schwierigkeit wo weniger Fürsorgepflicht
haben diese Menschen zu schützen die uns
informieren prominente Whistleblower
Assange schützt auch das neue Gesetz
deshalb nicht sie alle hatten geheime
Dokumente öffentlich gemacht
man nehme mit wachsender Sorge zur
Kenntnis was sich auf Twitter tue so
reagierte heute die Bundesregierung seit
Multimilliardär Elon Musk den
Kurznachrichtendienst übernommen hat
baute das Unternehmen nach seinem Gusto
um jetzt liest mask die Twitter konnten
von mehreren prominenten US-Journalisten
sperren die kritisch über ihn berichtet
hatten angeblich hätten sie außerdem
Daten von masks privatflügen
veröffentlicht und dadurch seine Familie
gefährdet fragen wir Elmar die Wissen in
Washington wie wird das Vorgehen masks
in den USA bewertet
also Elon mus stellt sich ja gern selber
als Verteidiger der Meinungsfreiheit da
und deshalb fällt die Kritik sehr scharf
aus an dieser Sperre ein Sprecher der
Vereinten Nationen hat es sogar als
gefährlichen pressedenzfall bezeichnet
die Journalisten bestreiten die Vorwürfe
sie haben kritisch berichtet dass Maske
eben suspendierte Konten von Hetzern
Rassisten Antisemiten wieder freigibt
dass er selber hetzt unter anderem
jüngst gegen den corona-experten der
US-Regierung Anthony dass er auch
Verschwörungstheorien befördert über
Twitter und das alles kann man auch
belegen und das hat wirtschaftliche
Folgen einerseits steigen verärgerte
Nutzer aus Twitter aus große Konzerne
haben ihre Werbung auf der Plattform
heruntergefahren und der wichtigste
Konzern von Elon Musk Tesla der Autor
Hersteller hat im vergangenen Jahr mehr
als 60% seines Werts in den Aktien
verloren da gibt's natürlich eine ganze
Reihe von Gründen dafür aber die
Investoren kritisieren vor allen Dingen
eben dass Elon Musk anderen Unternehmen
von ihm schadet durch seine Besessenheit
bei Twitter und durch impulsive
Entscheidungen wie jetzt eben auch diese
Entscheidung zur Sperre von Journalisten
danke für diese Einschätzung MRT wissen
war das live aus Washington
mittleren in Hessen ist ein Schlag gegen
darknet-foren mit sexualisierter Gewalt
an Kindern gelungen die drei aktuell
größten Plattformen mit hunderttausenden
Nutzern weltweit wurden abgeschaltet
sagt die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft
Frankfurt am Main und das BKA drei
Männer in Deutschland wurden
festgenommen sie sollen Fotos und Videos
von sexuellen Kindesmissbrauch zum
Tausch oder Kauf angeboten haben
in die Türkei in einem halben Jahr sind
dort Präsidentschaftswahlen aber schon
jetzt zeigt sich wie heftig der
Wahlkampf wird gerade wurde der mögliche
Herausforderer von Präsident Erdogan
wegen Beleidigung verurteilt dieses
Urteil ist mit einem Politikverbot für
ekremolu verbunden und würde verhindern
dass der populäre Bürgermeister von
Istanbul Präsidentschaftskandidat wird
mehr von Jörg Brase
nach dem Urteil gab sich imamolo vor
seinen Anhängern kämpferisch zweieinhalb
Jahre Gefängnis wegen Beamten
Beleidigung und ein Politikverbot
Istanbuls Bürgermeister wird das Urteil
anfechten das kann viele Monate dauern
so lange bleibt er auf freiem Fuß und
sieht sich als Opfer eines politischen
Komplotts der Regierung
sie wollten mich ins Gefängnis stecken
und als sie merkten dass der Richter
nicht so entscheiden würde wie Sie es
wünschen haben sie den Richter entfernt
und brachten einen neuen der dann die
geforderte Entscheidung traf
ein Sechser Bündnis der Opposition will
bei der Wahl im kommenden juni-präsident
Erdogan herausfordern noch hatten sich
die Parteien nicht auf einen gemeinsamen
Kandidaten geeinigt doch für
politikjournalistin Sevilla yilman ist
die Entscheidung nach diesem Urteil
gefallen
nur ein Bürgermeister man sprach über
eine mögliche Kandidatur aber er hatte
sich noch nicht erklärt seit dem Urteil
jedoch ist die mamulu der klare Favorit
seit dem Urteil ist er der Gegenkandidat
von Erdogan
der Präsident war am Tag des Urteils auf
Staatsbesuch im Ausland und wollte sich
bislang nicht zum Fall immer Mulu äußern
für Präsident Erdogan konnte das Urteil
zu einem politischen Bumerang werden
seine Wiederwahl ist auch wegen der
hohen Inflation alles andere als sicher
er Krimi mamulu könnte sich nun als
Märtyrer inszenieren im Kampf gegen ein
Regime das den Rechtsstaat mit Füßen
tritt vorausgesetzt das
Berufungsverfahren zieht sich hin und er
kann tatsächlich gegen Erdogan antreten
der Präsident hofft auf das kurze
Gedächtnis der Wähler gut sechs Monate
sind es noch bis dahin kann viel
passieren kann der Stern imamus auch
wieder verglühen
zur corona-pandemie in Deutschland gibt
es neue Daten es geht um die Sterbefälle
im Jahr 2021 so war covid 19 bei
71.331 Verstorbenen die ausschlaggebende
Todesursache nach Angaben des
Statistischen Bundesamts sind das 79%
mehr als im Jahr davor bei allen
registrierten Todesursachen 2021 lag der
Anteil von Corona bei 7%
ein geplatztes Aquarium das ist schon
bei normaler Größe in der Wohnung ein
Desaster in Berlin zerbarscht am frühen
Morgen das riesen Aquarium Aqua Dome
zwei Menschen wurden verletzt
so sah es mal aus ein 16 Meter hoher
Glaszylinder im Innenhof eines Hotels
ein Aufzug in der Mitte Inhalt eine
Million Liter Salzwasser und etwa 1.500
tropische Fische für die meisten davon
gab es keine Rettung das Erdgeschoss des
Hotels liegt in Trümmern romanescova
es war eine Berliner Touristenattraktion
das wohl größte freistehende Aquarium
der Welt gelegen in einem Hotel unweit
vom Berliner Dom Teil seltene Fische
fanden hier ihr zu Hause mit einem
Fahrstuhl konnte man sogar
hindurchfahren
heute früh um kurz vor 6 Uhr zabars der
riesige Zylinder Handyvideos zeigen das
Ausmaß der Zerstörung kümmer Teile
bedecken den Boden zwei Menschen werden
verletzt
erst nach dem Morgengrauen können Gäste
das Hotel verlassen viele wurden von
Knall aus dem Schlaf gerissen
und ich habe dann tatsächlich gedacht
ist irgendwie vielleicht ein kurzes
Erdbeben bin dann wieder eingeschlafen
und habe dann als der Wecker ging
gesehen dass die ganze Straße gesperrt
war dann googelt man natürlich und dann
habe ich das alles gesehen ja sehr trage
ich von oben gut zu erkennen mit welcher
Wucht Trümmerteile auch nach draußen
gedrückt wurden Drucker Blumenkübel
liegen verstreut auf der Straße und
veränderte Fische am Mittag verschafft
sich die Regierende Bürgermeisterin
einen Eindruck vor Ort sie spricht von
Glück um Unglück weil das Aquarium so
früh am Morgen geposten ist wenn sie das
Ausmaß sehen und sich vorstellen dass
dort voller Betrieb in allen Restaurants
gewesen wäre voller Betrieb im Fahrstuhl
mit Kindergruppen mit Schülergruppen die
hierher kommen das wäre furchtbar
gewesen die Ursache des Unglücks noch
unklar Berlin Senats Innenverwaltung
erklärte erster Anzeichen deuteten auf
Material Ermüdung hin genaueres müssen
die Ermittlungen zeigen
tja und jetzt stimmen wir uns schon mal
aufs Wochenende ein die Fußball-WM endet
ja mit dem großen Finale Frankreich
gegen Argentinien am Sonntag und dem
kleinen Finale morgen aber das Spiel um
Platz 3 das ist ja für viele viele
Millionen Menschen das Finale der Herzen
und die schlagen für die
Überraschungsmannschaft des Turniers
Marokko noch einmal im Wüstenstaat Katar
Geschichte schreiben der Auftrag für die
Atlas Löwen die Anstrengungen der
letzten Wochen sollen beim Kräftemessen
mit Kroatien keine Rolle spielen
das ist nicht schwierig denn diese
Gelegenheit hat es noch nie gegeben
Dritter bei dieser WM zu werden ist ein
großes Ziel für Marokko jeder möchte
dieses Match spielen jeder ist bereit
josef in nessiris Treffer gegen Portugal
hat sie längst und sterblich gemacht
weltweiter Jubel bei den marokkanischen
Fans und stolz als erstes afrikanisches
Land ins Halbfinale vorgedrungen zu sein
nach der Niederlage gegen Frankreich
wollen sie jetzt aus Podium
wir haben bereits eine große Show
geliefert angetrieben von unseren
außergewöhnlichen Fans all das zusammen
zeigt dass man sich immer an dieses Team
erinnern wird
morgen gegen Kroatien
zum Wintersport da gab es heute deutsche
Erfolge in der Nordischen Kombination
Natalie Armbruster erkämpfte beim
Weltcup in Ramsau den dritten Platz und
bei den Männern gab es ein spannendes
Duell zwischen Jens luraschs of the glow
und Vincent Geiger um den zweiten Platz
dass der Norweger mit einem mini mini
Vorsprung im Ziel für sich entschieden
den dritten deutschen Platz des Tages
holte sich Snowboarder Martin Nöll beim
Cross Weltcup Rennen in Cervinia und
Biathletin denise hermannweg wurde in Le
grande beim Sprint über 7,5 km sie ist
dritte
bis zum Schluss muss Denise Herrmann Weg
zittern denn eine junge Französin mit
der hohen Startnummer 86 hätte sie fast
vom Podest verdrängt knapp fünf Sekunden
drin die 23-Jährige Sophie schobo und
die 33-Jährige Denise Hermann Wick
wirklich cooles Rennen die ja die
Kulissen ist ja natürlich einzigartig
die Franzosen Kinder richtig ab
lediglich beim liegend Anschlag leistet
sich die deutsche ein Fehler insgesamt
bei zehn Schuss neuen Treffer dazu die
beste Laufzeit Rang drei also für Denise
Hermann Wick es gewinnt die Schwedin
Anna magnussson den Person komplettiert
den schwedischen Doppel Triumph
ja mehr Deutsche dritte Plätze habe ich
jetzt nicht zu vermelden
das Wochenende bringt weiterhin ruhiges
und eisiges Wetter mehr dazu hat gleich
östentelli um zehn begrüßt Sie Christian
Sievers im reuterjanal das 19 Uhr Team
sagt danke und tschüss und wünscht Ihnen
ein schönes Adventswochenende bis morgen
wenn Sie
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Ruhe vor dem
Sturm ist erst einmal angesagt mit
diesem Hoch hier das verstärkt sich es
sorgt immer noch für eisige Nächte ja
und äh auch für Sonnenschein und das
Tief auf dem Atlantik ist ein Sturmtief
das pustet mit warmer Luft die kalte
davon und ersetzt sie es wird also
deutlich milder Anfang der kommenden
Woche wir schauen mal auf die Details im
Südosten zieht der Schnee ab es bleibt
glatt auf den Straßen auch nach Westen
hindurch überfriedene Nässe bei minus 15
Grad im Südwesten Deutschlands und -3
Grad Richtung Nordsee Morgen viel Sonne
vor allem in der Mitte und auch nach
Westen wenn der Nebel verschwindet in
östlichen Landesteilen ist es Dichter
bewölkt bei höchsten Temperaturen
zwischen -8 und 0 Grad also ein
frostiger Tag die kommenden Tage am
Sonntag noch mal frostig aber viel
sonnen im Süden Nebel bei -8 bis +5 Grad
Montag kommt dann das Sturmtief auf
bringt gefrienen Regen mit große Glätte
dazu Sturmböen und im Süd und
Temperaturen bis 14 Grad am Dienstag ein
schönen Abend